talking with Julia in New York she makes
30,000 year her husband makes minimum
wage occasionally keeps the kids at rest
the time he has a high interest loan on
his truck and she owes 19 thousand
dollars on a car that's now worth nine
or ten is that a fair summary of what
you told me yes you have two problems I
you have two problems you have a car
problem and an income problem both of
you and I know he had some legal
problems but that does not preempt him
from starting a self-employed idea and
making a bazillion dollars has owning
his own company
and he can go do that nothing stops him
from doing that except maybe in certain
industries based on his conviction for
whatever it was he was convicted for but
you're not regulated to minimum-wage
jobs just because you have a record okay
my I I'm completely fine with getting
getting rid of my car my plan that I was
coming up with and I talked to my father
he's a pastor basically we're going to
be coming into about ten thousand
dollars to work with to start this where
did it come from with our tax returns so
how are you getting a $10,000 tax return
on a thirty thousand dollar income I
have four children and I make well I
guess little enough that that's what we
usually bring that and bring home Wow
and I do put more money in I think I
think I said in the beginning like when
I did might start my job four years ago
I put four in or have them take more out
now type things now too much being
withheld in addition to that okay that
would be the only way you get there I
think you I mean you're going to qualify
for an unearned income tax credit but
not ten grand on 30 you don't have that
many kids um
yeah anyway so yeah that's helpful so
what is his truck worth I don't know his
truck is worth it's like a two
and for Dodge Dakota but I don't think
it's worth what we owe on it and if we
don't pay it off like really soon we're
gonna pay for it three times because of
the 24% interest is how I look at it how
I look at it as you sell it
okay and get rid of 2003
interest okay yeah you don't twenty four
percent interest is what's known as
insanity and so we sell the truck get
rid of that let's take the 10 grand buy
$1000 get around car and use the arrest
of the 10 grand to get out of your car
and get another thousand dollar get
around car now we got two thousand two
thousand two one thousand dollar hoop
Dee's that were barely existing in and
at least we got no payments you're
starting to have your life back and then
the other side of the equation is you
guys have to work on the income side of
your equation just all over the desk you
know yeah he's got he's doing his own
business and he seems to be starting out
pretty good with that but at the same
time right now it's like everything that
he gets coming in is going right into
the business right now like just to keep
it going that's not the definition of
starting out really good I'm starting
out really good as you're making up
money that some goes into the businesses
some comes home right now he's spending
everything in the business that he makes
that's known as a hobby so far what kind
of business he does custom fishing lures
and yet he like spray paints them and
makes any even makes the bodies and
basically he has a pretty big customers
that are buying you know they could
spend a hundred dollars on six lures and
he can do that in his spare time while
he's home with the kids a hundred
dollars on six lures is not fixing that
I mean how much of this volume has he
done of this I mean like I said it's
been within the first year and I really
haven't gotten into it too much with him
because I haven't asked him for money in
this I just wanted him to be able to do
his I'd try to start something and I've
been able to I thought I was able to I
want you guys to combine your finances
combine your lives and combine your
goals and his business exists not for
his pleasure his business
exists to provide for his wife and
children and so his wife doesn't need to
speak into it didn't know whether it's
making money or not and I don't want
whether you've sold two hundred dollars
of these lures or two hundred thousand
dollars of these lures I think it's two
hundred dollars and Bubba's feeling good
about himself I'm not feeling good about
him yet he needs to go he needs to make
a whole bunch of these lures and be
selling them and not just making enough
that he feels good about himself
I want him making some dadgum money like
forty or fifty thousand dollars a year
is what I want making and I don't smell
that in this situation so you guys need
to get together work on your financial
goals together work on your career and
income goals together and when you lay
all of that out you're going to begin to
make progress that's going to involve
some both these cars but I don't want to
sell these cars and then stay poor I
want to sell the cars so I get out so I
got a way out of this mess and have a
game plan to get out I've been broke
kiddo but I've never been poor poor as a
state of mind so hold on I'm going to
send you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover to help you with that and
I'm going to send him a copy of the book
on Terry leadership to help him grow his
business because I want both of you to
win thanks for this call hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show